what would you like to hit a rap about
adult circumcision mmm this yeah is this
something a lot of men just crossing
their legs they're like or their I can't
see the person who said that is it
something that you've been through your
father sit it's your father in jail no
he's fine it's heavy wing it if he was
next to you just like under I succeeded
there you go
so why did he suggest it was he trying
to get you to convert to Judaism or was
it just a tight foreskin thing
it's not funny women right a lot of men
have tight four skills which means when
they get an erection which is a lot
because we're men it's kind of Tears
there it's not fun or nice so calm down
so neither of those were you he felt
guilty or just lonely just oh come on
son we got on the beach should be too
[ __ ] circumcised let's just wander
around just be like yeah more
aerodynamic but uh you know where do you
keep your change if you don't have one
that's my my question so adult
circumcision great thank you very much
that was a brilliant suggestion I like
it if you are not on a white chair but
are still on this side of the room Pat's
on a stool standing what would you like
to hear a rap that I I heard I heard
Azkaban next stop Azkaban brilliant you
look way too cool to read Harry Potter
you have your shades tugging your shirt
down into one of those little temporary
v-necks I like it when men do that it's
like oh it's a scoop neck until you want
to show you pecs off you hang those
shades shows the heavy good-quality
probably Italian you got some money
next stop Azkaban really everyone here
would have [ __ ] you and then they were
like oh but he likes wizards
I bet when you come you go expecto
patronum to be honest the fat mayo
laughter that suggests they're all on
board with Harry Potter so that you may
be in adult circumcision
next stop Azkaban just gonna say there's
three more suggestions left those two a
[ __ ] stellar done
don't balls this up will come to the
anyone who's not a white chair on this
side of the room you're really scared
now you're like don't worry if it's just
average but I haven't had it before I'll
still take it we're just all feel
disappointed I'm not being serious I
don't mind what you suggest we can't
give you thinking time okay people on
the white chairs on this side what would
you like a rack that spin spin what
spinifex well clearly by the fact that
I'm standing here going
no what is spinifex kind of like a plant
Oh the grass plant that breaks Oh a
tumbleweed kind of like a tuck I feel
that you could have led with that really
but I I admire that I admire that thing
of light I'm gonna make him look like an
idiot and then be like I mean it's just
a tumbleweed really it's like I had one
guy who's like the epididymis and we're
all like what the [ __ ] that
and I need played out for a long time
and then one who's just the bit that
connects your balls to your dick
I like that so a spinifex which is we've
all learned a new word tonight well done
us may also add all circumcision and
next up Azkaban guys you've had me
thinking time now and it sounds like a
[ __ ] fight is kicking off out there
so if you don't make a suggestion or
invite them in get them to squeeze it
out here do you speak English this is
not the show for you if English is not
your first language you will struggle a
great deal with some of these
Rumplestiltskin okay
is there something about Rumplestiltskin
that you really kind of you know enjoy
also do you find intriguing about it
just the sound of the word okay you know
the story though vaguely that's all
right
I'm not going to start slacking someone
off when I was clearly just not knowing
what tumbleweed was Rumpelstiltskin and
the sound of the word spinifex adult
circumcision
next up Azkaban let's get one final one
I'll say it and come from anywhere in
the room but I'm pretty much guessing
it's not gonna come from over the head
it's really gonna be in this kidney
shape in what you guys want to wrap out
final one I heard three but you said
some of that benefits tax bit someone
said something up there and people
laughed what was it
overweight firemen cool Yeah right yeah
you know it's fun to mock them after all
the good they'll be doing for the last
six weeks
right the fires have stopped now we're
just gonna back to roasting you it's
good right yeah that was not deliberate
word choice don't don't put this on
Twitter a building all right
okay spinifex Rumpelstiltskin next to
Azkaban adult circumcision overweight
fireman I like those suggestions these
this is gonna be fun this lovely people
is gonna be a freestyle rap that's a rap
made up on the spot base in town those
suggestions do not worry will not be
anywhere near is atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you are expecting
a privately educated middle class white
boy to be
a lot of you seem very unconvinced don't
worry okay thank you for watching just a
small reminder that you have until the
end of Sunday the 21st of June to get
your entry in for the drop the beat
goods challenge cannot wait to see what
you guys come up with
enjoy the rap that's a drop that beat
him do this I'm gonna start with yours I
think because that's probably the most
difficult ones are going to kick off we
can really get some definition in there
[Music]
you said a word on the thought what's
next wish I had a dictionary that I
could inspect I would turn right to s
pinc what the [ __ ] is the definition
again the spinifex never heard before
but when I'm in America yeah you know I
saw I'm deep down south everyone collect
us getting our thoughts when with their
in Texas see a little very cool shape
are you breeder it is a very nice
tumbleweed minute reads many leaves
men and lots of detritus and just hit
there cowboy role buyers got a little
horses the spirits and we say giddyup
spinifex pizza brass it keeps up with
the speed of the wind because it's
carried by the breeze separate air yes I
would agree separate sound like Severus
if we're in the Harry Potter world
glamorous that's a nice thing the air
respect the Zedd and the SS which they
pronounce instead come in doesn't matter
you late ma'am welcome in stop Azkaban
if this was a comedy show why don't
everybody cheer the lady doesn't know so
confused walking late it's okay all
Dementors are my mates if I was Sirius
Black Card escaped Azkaban and I never
go back but one thing I must impress
there's no stop Azkaban cut the Hogwarts
Express just goes from Kings Cross
station on the platform 9 and 3/4 then
he goes up north Begley said the
Highlands of Scotland doesn't go to
Azkaban doesn't even stop sir doesn't
pick anybody up on the way and when you
get off
Oh Lorraine is the thestral that's a
horse you can only see if you've seen
someone tie if you've seen their disease
yeah of you are as nerdy as me but
that's totally fine Aaron flirt in with
you if you've got a big dick and the
skins gone that's okay yeah man I don't
want one I really don't like the balance
with all the flesh I really like it when
the Jews get a little bit less chopping
up the top they have consent they're
God's people they've removed 10% and it
just shows off that shiny Hill it's like
II wanna touch it
give you a thrill but one thing between
your thighs if you ever get adult
circumcised John then you get less
sensitivity because it rubs against you
dream so frequently and so it's harder
to come even if you see a nice person's
bum
I didn't say lady or man cuz I'm
gender-fluid adult circumcision
everybody should do it let's go now
let's remove it what would the story be
if we used it if you took the skin away
it would be Rumple stilt anyway that's a
clever little joke link it to the fairy
tale you like the way it sounds you you
thought you want it inhale on that
because I left the last syllable baby
the story remember double tell your
sympathy it's a weird little man he goes
home stuff into clothes weaving the
thread there's a baby not old I'm going
over there oh it's such a shame I steal
it if you can't guess my name so the
parents of the baby side just made two
guesses Leo or wife no it's a much
weirder walk but they crept up behind
like Polonius behind an aerosol blinds
in Hamlet and tried to listen in and
said oh [ __ ] he's cool Rumpelstiltskin
they cheated on him then they worked it
out like a mental gym if I was energy in
my diet plan would go out the window cuz
I'm a fireman everyone is not surprised
I just wanna eat pies when I'm out there
spread water on
I let my hoes go like I'm risen from my
circumcised dick they need to be more
careful of the food they pick because
they're all overweight they need to
start shedding it otherwise all weight
the great weight on the ladder starts
falling before a little by a man who
used to be falling but now he's
paralyzed in a wheelchair he's so fat
over where you can't feel there but it's
his fault for breaking the pole need to
set a much lower weight goal joined
Weight Watchers lead the service go to a
hospital and get them to circumcise and
that will lose 10 grams probably have
not weighed the balls of a man
[Applause]